[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor welcome listening
friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact during the famous Battle of
New Orleans in 1815 10,000 trained
British soldiers attacked 4700 American
defenders Andrew Jackson's army made up
of a motley assortment of militia
fighters frontiersmen slaves Indians and
even pirates were outnumbered two to one
incredibly they still won a decisive
victory during the bloody back of the
battle the British lost about 2,000
soldiers and the Americans about three
hundred and thirty in addition over two
thousand were wounded sadly this costly
battle turned out to be entirely
unnecessary a peace treaty had been
signed between Great Britain and the
United States two weeks earlier but the
good news was too slow and reaching
across the Atlantic to the battlefield
few things are sadder than a wasted
sacrifice you know the Bible teaches us
that the greatest sacrifice in history
has been wasted by most people stay with
his friends we're going to learn more on
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions
so welcome listening friends if you
would like to call in with your Bible
question we have lines open right now
800 463 1797 that's 800 God says we're
also streaming this on Facebook if you
want to take a peek at what's happening
here in the studio in Granite Bay
California and we're down in the
basement quite literally but that's
simply the Doug Batchelor Facebook page
or the amazing facts Facebook page once
again if you call now good chance you'll
get your question on tonight's program
Bible questions eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven and I am Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening friends and as they always do
let's start the program with prayer your
Father in Heaven we thank you that were
able open your word and study together
it's indeed a light to our path guides
it's a clear and full understanding of
your will for our lives and Lord we ask
your blessing on those who are listening
some who might be in their car others at
home those listening on the Internet
Lord and we just ask that you guide us
all into a clear understanding of the
Bible for we asked us in Jesus name Amen
amen a pastor day you spoke about a you
know a battle that I guess at first one
might think well great victory you know
against the odds the u.s. they were able
to defend New Orleans but really all of
that effort and all the bloodshed at the
end of the day was actually in vain
because the peace treaty had already
been signed they just didn't know about
it I know can you imagine when they did
finally here and you know parents heard
that their their kids fought in a battle
that was totally unnecessary and so it's
you know it was a great victory and some
argue well you know if we had lost the
battle maybe the British were taking New
Orleans and they were going to try and
stop Jefferson from keeping Napoleon's
Louisiana Purchase you know you could
always second-guess history but it still
makes you think about how sad a wasted
sacrifice is and friends you probably
know where I'm going with this the Bible
tells us that Jesus died for the sins of
the whole world you can
read in 2nd Corinthians 5:14 and 15 for
the love of Christ compels us because we
judged us that if one died for all then
all died and he died for all that those
who should live no longer for themselves
but for him who died for them and rose
again you know twice here it says Jesus
died for all there are some churches
that teach jesus only died for the elect
but the Bible says he died for whosoever
will come to him here twice it says he
died for all and yet narrow is the way
that leads to life because the sacrifice
of Jesus is not being taken advantage of
by most of the world most of the people
who have ever lived they choose not to
follow God and and many from the time of
Christ to the present even though they
may have heard about Jesus they still
don't believe it or they choose to live
selfishly and it's so sad that he
suffered for their sins and they're not
going to take advantage of it and
they're gonna suffer for their sins -
and so we just appeal to people that if
you only realize that Christ has paid
for your sins so you don't need to but
you must accept his sacrifice and don't
let it be in vain and we have a free
offer that will talk about how much he's
paid for you and how you can accept that
beautiful sacrifice and have the victory
in everlasting life the book that we
have this evening is called the high
cost of the Cross and we'd be happy to
send this to anyone who asks again ask
for our free offer this evening it's the
high cost of the Cross the number to
call for that is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven that is
our resource phone line and again we
want to encourage you to ask for our
free offer it's a book entitled the high
cost of the cross if you have a Bible
related question a phone line here in
the studio is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven eight hundred four six
three seventy to ninety seven our first
caller this evening we've got Joseph who
is listening from is that Bobby
abu-dhabi yeah all right well Joseph
welcome to the program oh thank you and
your question yes
yes all right now so the question is
about in first King 1722 when Elijah is
staying with his widow and she has a son
the son dies and he's in the Upper Room
and Elijah prays and says the soul of
the child came back into him again the
word soul there means that his life just
returned his breath of life came back he
had been dead and it doesn't mean that
there was this conscious ghost that was
floating around that somehow Rhian
habited the body so it's just saying his
life came back into him again you know
if you look at the word they translated
from the original Hebrew it's translated
as soul but it's also translated as life
117 times translated as person 29 times
the mind 15 times so the word is used
depending upon the context and I think
it's quite clear in the context here
that the child was revived his life came
back and as I said that does fit in with
the meaning of the word means life
mm-hmm thank you appreciate that so much
Joseph all right next caller that we
have is so funny listening from South
Carolina
so finally welcome to the program hi
doing great thanks for calling that
amazing fact I started it three years
ago I never finished it and I didn't
have anything better to do during the
pandemic so I got it all my cousin's on
zoom' and we finish all 24 books and we
did sort of full of prophecy and it oh
praise the Lord and that's a great great
encouragement to others out there
take the amazing facts Bible study
course it'll in richer time yeah and
your question this evening I was
studying with someone and my cousin and
he told me that Jesus was the first
thing that got created I don't believe
it but he gave me two bodies worthless
Colossians chapter 1 verses 13 and 14 I
believe it says something about the
firstborn of creation and then proverbs
chapter 22 there's something about he is
the thing that was created how do I
explain to him that Jesus is not a
creation I gave him 1 John 1 verses 1 to
4 it says that it's not enough so he
told about Jesus declaration anyway well
the word firstborn in Hebrew that was
always that meant the the most beloved
the firstborn I always had a double
portion of the father's blessing it's
not telling us that Jesus was created
there because you read in other places
all things and this is in the Gospel of
John chapter 1 all things that were made
were made by him and without him was not
anything made that was made so if all
things were made by Jesus well he didn't
make himself and he's the creator the
Bible tells us that he shares with the
the characteristics of the Father now if
God is love in order to be loved
of course if God has always been loved
you have to have someone to love if
Jesus was created then God was not
always loved and again the Bible calls
Jesus from everlasting to everlasting I
am God that's eternity past eternity
present so you know one of the important
definitions of God is he is
self-existent he was not created the
problem you have if Jesus was created he
is not God he is a creation he's a
creature yeah let me add just a few
extra verses to that that I think help
of course we know Jesus was the first
born of Mary and we know that the
firstborn son even all the way back in
the old
and was a type of Christ and when Paul
refers to the firstborn it's talking
about the inheritor the one who is to
inherit Jesus coming to this earth being
the firstborn of mankind is now the
inheritor of the kingdom of the earth is
the key inheritor of the earth and we
can see this if we compare with a few
other verses Romans chapter 8 verse 29
says talking about Christ for whom he
also for knew he predestined to be
conformed to the image of his son that
he might be the firstborn among many
brethren mm-hmm so the context there was
the Christ is the firstborn amongst the
believers he is the leader and
Colossians 1:15 talks about the
firstborn over all creation so Christ
being the firstborn of God receives all
creation it's really talking about the
Incarnation when Jesus came took upon
himself humanity of course he existed
before that you can find that in the Old
Testament but here in this sense Jesus
taking upon himself humanity it's the
first born also first one pastor like I
think we can add it's not just time we
think of first born as a sequence but
it's also first born of position and
authority
you probably heard the illustration
about the first lady has been the
president's wife she's the first lady
not the first woman sequential ated but
exactly just first in position and
ranked and so likewise Christ is the
first in position and rank yep so
hopefully you know we have a book we can
send you so funny and it's called it's
about the Trinity and that talks about
the eternal nature of Jesus and you just
call we'll send you a free copy all
right the number again to call for that
is just simply go to or just call 883
five six seven four seven and you can
answer the book on the Trinity you can
also read that are online at the amazing
facts website richard is listening in
Montana rich
[Music]
such as our woman passes and there's 11
I sent him about like a woman to have
authority over the man but to be in
silence yes what I just want to find out
what does the Bible really mean and say
about that all right
good question let me read this for our
friends who may be listening and it says
let a woman learn in silence and this
again is first Timothy chapter 2 verse
11 and 12 let a woman learn in silence
with all subjection in the roles of men
and women in the family and in the
church well yes we do see that in the
Bible you do not see an example in the
Bible of women serving in the capacity
of pastor priest apostle you do see
women in the Bible serving in the
capacity of prophetess and so you know
if a woman's a prophetess then obviously
God speaking through them the Bible
tells us about Phillip the Evangelist
who has four dollar daughters that could
prophesy and some of this is I think
some of it is cultural in that Paul is
talking about where women were sitting
in separate places from the men as they
did in in some of the churches back then
and the women were sort of embarrassing
their husbands because they were
teaching them publicly and disrupting
the services and Paul is saying and I'll
tell the woman to be silent ask their
husbands at home you know but let the
husband have the role of the the priest
leader in the family so we have a book
we can send you a free copy of that
Richard and it's called women the in
ministry and the number to call for that
if you'd like to receive it is just
simply eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and again we will
be happy to send that to anyone who
calls an ass it's called one mini
ministry and I think you'll find it
encouraging especially for women out
there yes there is a place that God has
for service for men and women in the
church but he does make some
distinctions with roles and I think
you'd find it helpful the next photo
that we have is Chris listening from
Florida Chris welcome to the program
yes Thank You class girls yeah
thank you for taking my call I have
another question you know we had the
stillborn
a child with my wife a few years ago and
I was wondering you what do you think
what happens to the babies which were
born but dead do they go to heaven or do
they like the rest of believers and
unbelievers you know expect immediately
wait for judgment or and death to be
resurrected at the second coming of
Christ what do you think that's a good
question and you know it's a difficult
question
first of all I'll tell you what I do see
in Scripture is that the children of
believing parents they will be in the
resurrection of the just and I believe
angels will take those children and
place them in the arms of their parents
the the more difficult question is will
every stillborn or aborted child through
history of the saved and lost all be in
the resurrection in in heaven and I
think it's it's hard to comprehend that
you know if someone says oh I insist
that they will be well I'm not going to
try and change their mind there is a
verse in the Bible in the book of Job
and job 3:16 where he says you know that
I might have been like a stillborn child
like an infant who never saw the light
and he goes on to sort of wish he had
not existed and so it may be that the
aborted or stillborn children of
unbelievers maybe as though they had not
been they certainly won't be judged
because they're not guilty of anything
so but I do believe the scripture that
promises that the children who died
before the
age of accountability of believers and
what's that verse in 1st Corinthians 7
it says your children are sanctified by
the unbelieving parent about the
believing parent right yeah and then of
course chapter 2 verse 18 talking about
the slaughter of the the little baby
boys in Bethlehem there's a prophecy
that 3:30 matthew 2:18 that says they
shall return from the land of the enemy
meaning death so it's talking about
those those children that were killed so
for a believer yes we have hope we look
forward to the resurrection and but that
happens at the second coming right the
dating Christ don't precede us to heaven
yeah they're not they're not in a
nursery in a holding pattern until the
parents come right they come with the
parents does that help Chris I'm sorry
did you mention the 1st Corinthians 7
and what well well we'll let's look that
up real quick and the verse I refer to
was Matthew chapter 2 and verse 18 I was
talking about 1st Corinthians 7 where he
says where they deceive oh yeah he says
in verse 14 for the unbelieving husband
is sanctified by the wife meaning the
believing wife and the of an unbelieving
wife is sanctified by the husband the
believing husband otherwise your
children would be unclean but now they
are wholly speaking of you know children
before the age of accountability and so
there's a sanctifying influence that the
believing parents have on on the
children so if you got a believing
parent even if it's one believing parent
and they have children and if they die
before the age of accountability where
then at that point they're responsible
for their own sins at the age of
accountability but before that they are
basically covered by the prayers and the
the faith of the believing parent all
right thank you thanks so much we hope
that helps Cris we got Katrina listening
from North Dakota
Katrina welcome to the program hello hi
how can we help you tonight um I've been
discovering the Sabbath the last couple
years but I have lots of friends at them
who aren't Sabbath keepers without
coming across as like judgmental how do
i lovey tell them about it
well you know you could just say the
Lord has shown me something that has
been a real blessing can I share that
with you and if they're open then you
share it and there's you know lots of
great material you probably run into
that can make that very clear you sure
don't want to push because like you said
you know that that can you can be
obnoxious and drive people away that way
but there's three things you do for
those that you care about and you love
to reach them you try and be a good
witness if they're interested you share
information with them and then you pray
that God will soften their heights and
hearts and they're open to the truth
whatever that truth might be that you
want to share with them and so you know
amazing facts has some great material
and websites if you've not seen the
website Katrina Sabbath truth calm then
there's a lot of material there for
anyone who wants to know more about that
alright again we want to encourage you
to take a look at that website called
Sabbath truth comm and we also do have
some resources if as pastor Doug
mentioned people are open to hearing
that we do have our amazing facts study
guide calls one of the presentations
deals with the Sabbath it's called last
day of history and we'll be happy to
send there do anyone who calls it asks
or if you'd like you can take the whole
course or share the whole course is
twenty-seven lessons in all you can
share there with somebody else for free
so you can call and ask for that the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven thank you for your call
Katrina we've got Cape listening from
Brooklyn New York Kate welcome to the
program oh good evening pastors thank
you for which is if Christian is forced
to get vaccinated is it considered as a
sane because if you cannot work relocate
or even stay at your own home without
being vaccinated what are the choices
you will have so forcefully vaccinate
you it a and what Christians do thank
you yeah that's a good question and I've
had other people that have asked me not
on the program but they've
privately you know what if the
government discovers a vaccine and they
say look everybody has to get this
vaccine there are some schools a matter
of fact in North America I think mmm
the requiring vaccination of kids in
school yeah school and so some
governments have and states have voted
that you have to vaccinate your kids for
them to go to public school what do you
do well if a person's got a strong moral
compunction that there's something
morally wrong with that you know you
need to obey your conscience if if you
know if they discover a vaccine and the
vaccines proven to be effective and
low-risk
it's unfortunate personally I'm opposed
to the government making those decisions
I think it takes away a certain amount
of your freedom it's kind of like when
they say you've got to wear a helmet
when you ride a motorcycle at least in
California but you don't in Texas or
some states and you know there's all
kinds of arguments about well it's my
head and someone says yeah but it's our
taxes paying for your hospital bills and
they go round and round on that one so
you just have to you know pray that God
will give you wisdom that you can make
the right decision
now of course Pastor like we're not
saying that it's that it's wrong to get
a vaccine no but again that's a personal
decision I think the concern would come
in where a person is being forced and
everyone's a little different so that's
where we prayerfully need to pray for
God yeah yeah if it's a moral issue you
want to follow what you think is morally
right so appreciate that thank you so
much Kate hope that helps a little bit
all right next full of it we have is
Richard listening from Georgetown Guyana
Richard welcome to the program yes thank
you very much thank you yeah my question
tonight is on the body unjust road in
Luke 16 I would like a little clearer
explanation as to why if master would
have commended him for doing injecting
well that's a good that's a great
question I actually preached a sermon
called a shrewd
dude and it's on the unjust servant are
the shrewd servant Jesus is not
commending him for his deception Jesus
is commending him because he thought
ahead about his future and he made
preparation for his future and he built
alliances and relationships to preserve
him in his future and he said look this
unjust servant had enough sense to think
I'm going to be unemployed I need to
make friends with my masters creditors
and if I make friends and they'll
receive me into their homes because they
become accomplices with me in my crime
and Jesus is not commending him for his
dishonesty he's just saying even the
wicked think ahead and prepare for their
earthly future why aren't we thinking
ahead and making an arrangement an
alliance a relationship for our eternal
future that's what he's commending him
for not for his dishonesty but for
thinking ahead and just add to that past
that I his success was making alliances
building relationships with certain
individuals that could help him and I
think the contrast that Jesus is drawing
is for the believer we want to think
ahead we want to make sure that we've
built a relationship with our only hope
of having our debts removed and that's
Jesus Christ so we come into a saving
relationship with Christ which is our
only hope of salvation yes thank you for
your call Richard we've got Katherine
listening from Washington State
Katherine welcome to the program thank
you for taking my call I really
appreciate your show I have a question
from judges 11 about Jeptha when in
verse 30 and 31 he made a vow to the
Lord that if he would help him conquer
the ammonites then he would burn the
first person coming out of his house did
the Lord and it was his daughter his
only child that came out and he said you
know you had brought me to the dust I
can I have made a vow to the Lord and I
cannot take it back right so she goes
into the hills for two months and with
her
and then she comes back and it says in
39 she returned to her father who did
his knee it's out so she was never
married so I don't know if that means
she just didn't get married or if he
really did burn her yes all right well
let's look at the it's important to look
at verse 31 again
yeah Jeff that doesn't say whoever comes
out of the doors of my house he says he
says whatever comes out of the doors of
my house now when when people back then
said their house they meant their land
and the they had goats and sheep and
cows and oxen and donkeys and he was
gonna offer whatever came out first now
I used to have goats and whenever I came
home they were came around and up to me
and they had small ranches back then
they all lived on and he meant whenever
I come back victorious whatever comes
out to me he wasn't he's only got one
daughter he has no sons so why would he
deliberately say yeah whoever comes out
I'm gonna offer as a burnt offering the
custom back then was that you could
consecrate one of your children to the
Lord as a Nazarite and this is what
Hannah did she gave Samuel to the Lord
what he did is he gave his daughter to
the service of the temple she did not
die she could never marry and have
children and it proves that because
later it says the daughters in Israel
would go and bewail the virginity of
Jephthah's daughter she was alive they
would see her hey thank you we're gonna
take a break real quick be right back
friends don't go away
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and include the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
chart and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore com or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 spoke page or amazing
facts facebook page and you can see
what's happening here in the studio and
I am Doug Batchelor my name is Sean Ross
we've got Patti listening from Spokane
Washington penny welcome to the program
hi thanks for taking my call
yeah and your question tonight my
question is I don't exactly know where
to find it in the Bible I'm sorry sorry
but as a Christian woman I know that I
escaped judgment but I've heard the
verse that we will have to make and
account to God for every idle word that
was said do you know what I'm talking
about it's that's actually Matthew 12 I
could read it to you real quick
Matthew 12 verse 34 I'll start there
Jesus is talking to the scribes and
Pharisees he says brood of vipers how
can you being evil speak good things for
out of the abundance of the heart the
mouth speaks
a good man out of the good treasure of
his heart brings forth good things and
an evil man out of the evil treasure
brings forth evil things but I say to
you that for every idle word that men
shall speak they will give an account
thereof in the day of judgment for by
your words you'll be justified and by
your words you'll be condemned and you
could put that together with
Ecclesiastes I think it's chapter 7
where it says let your words be few when
you go to the house of the Lord so yeah
you know Christians yeah you know God
will forgive our sins as we repent and
confess
but Christians as well as anybody we
need to be careful in our in our words
and usually our words are flowing from
the heart you've got a friend that loves
football it seems like he's always
talking about football and if you've got
a friend that's in love with his new
fiance he's always talking about this is
wonderful
so you know the mouth usually reflects
what's in the heart right i it just it
sounded like judgment to me like we're
gonna be judged for every idle word that
we say and I'm well you know Jesus is
telling us that there is a day of
judgment it Paul says even to the church
we must all stand before the judgment
seat of Christ so there's a judgment for
everybody it says every knee will bow
and every tongue will confess and but in
the judgment if we have been walking
with the Lord if we confess and forsake
our sins like right now if I'm going to
be judged for every word that I've
spoken in every idle word I'm in big
trouble but what I do is you know I I
continually repent when I say I when I
recognize I've said something that's ill
'va ill-advised I repent and I asked the
Lord sometimes I'll say something I'll
say you know Doug that was a very
selfish thing to say and it tells me
there's selfishness in my heart or I say
something and I think Oh dad that was
very proud and then it tells me my heart
needs needs some attention in that area
so I think the Lord does want believers
to be conscious of what we're saying and
that it is something we give an account
for now as like I said as we confess and
repent of our sins he covers our sins so
speaking is one of the many sins that
Jesus covers you know what I'm saying
yeah but we do need to confess and
repent as we're aware of things right
yeah and it helps if someone told me
once that every every day a person
speaks enough words to fill a book with
320 pages and
that means you got a lot of books in a
year and over the course of your life
you got just a whole Smithsonian library
full of things that you said and
sometimes I get letters and amazing
facts because I misspeak because I do so
many sermons and so much teaching it's
not unusual for me to say something that
you're wrong you know either ill-advised
or I misspeak just a slip of the tongue
and there's that verse that says in the
multitude of words sin is not lacking so
we we just need to be aware be careful
what you say when you do say have
something worth saying and ask God to
forgive us if we slip up thanks for your
call Patti we've got Karen oh you know
what whew we got a Karen we get a book
we do we have any trouble that's the one
I was thinking of we got a book called
tiny troublemakers talks about our words
and we were happy to send this to anyone
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven that is the resource phone line
not speaking yes you can ask for the
book called tiny troublemakers and
sometimes what we say can cause a lot of
trouble all right we've got Karen
listening from Canada British Columbia
Karen you on the air
hi pastors I'm so glad to talk to you
your ministry is such a blessing to me
it's been four years and certainly has
helped me I could use that book you just
talked about me a bit lately I seem to
be a little bit as a Christian I don't I
don't like that so I'll probably ask for
that but why I'm calling is I'd like to
know or have some advice on how I could
reach my sister-in-law who who feels
she's good enough as she is she's a very
nice person really bubbly personality
smiley laughing you know she she doesn't
do bad things she doesn't drink or smoke
but yet she feels good feel like she
needs Jesus yeah no she doesn't I'm not
sure what or how to say cuz I've not
been the best example either you know
over the years I haven't always been a
Christian so she probably doesn't give
me any credit does she well whether she
believes you're a Christian or not let's
just find out does she believe that the
Bible is true I think so yes
so does she know what sin is yes
does she believe she's ever sinned
that's a good one I don't she's never
admitted that she just she just comes
out and says well I you know I do things
but I I know I'm a good person in that
spot but we're not yeah oh the penalty
for sin is death if she does not accept
the sacrifice of Jesus one sin is enough
to put anybody in the lake of fire and
so we all need to record the Bible says
all have fallen short of the glory of
God all we like sheep have gone astray
everyone is sin and they need to
recognize that so that's something you
might just ask her and say you know we
all need Jesus we've all sinned even the
small sins are deadly and yeah there's
no such thing as a little sand it's an
oxymoron mm-hmm okay I'll give that a
try
pray for me all right well pray God
gives you wisdom thanks so much
Karen and yeah you can ask for that book
on the tiny troublemaker talks about the
importance of godly speech for
Christians we've got Denise listening
from Rhode Island
Denise welcome to the program hi pastor
and I just love your program thank you
so much my question I was thinking you
know when we become grafted and we
become spiritual juices would it be
something that we should do is worship
Sabbath's instead of going to church on
Sunday what are your thoughts on that
yeah well we believe that the the
Sabbath is one of the Ten Commandments
we're not saved by keeping the law but
believers when they love the Lord they
will want to keep God's commandments and
the Sabbath is one of those Commandments
God says to remember it's largely
neglected by people in the Christian
world today and there's no question that
the seventh day is the Sabbath so I know
there's a lot of lovely Christians that
love the Lord that go on Sunday but
that's not the biblical day the biblical
day that Jesus went in the early church
they all went on the seventh day of the
week it wasn't until a couple hundred
years later that they garage
we began to keep two days and then they
neglected the seventh day you know we
didn't mention the the study guy that
talks about this called the last day of
history and I think yep you're right as
Christians we are the spiritual heirs
according to the promises made to
Abraham but there are also
responsibilities as spiritual Jews and
the Ten Commandments needs to be the
guide for our life and this Ten
Commandments talk about the seventh day
seven I will be happy to send the study
guide to anyone who asks or you can go
look at all both and go look at the
website it's called Sabbath truth comm
and it's just filled with all kind of
resources I think Denise you'd really
enjoy that also call and ask for the
study guide last day of history the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and I think you'll find that an
encouraging read makes one of the behalf
JD listening from Missouri JD from Wolf
Springs yes hello all right before hi
before I ask my question I just want the
other lady question reminded me of
Ecclesiastes 12:13 14 let us hear the
conclusion of the whole matter fear God
and keep his Commandments for this is
the whole duty of man right for God
shall bring every work into judgment she
said it was referring to judgment with
every secret thing whether it be good or
whether it be evil that's right and your
question my question yeah my question
was Matthew 24 verse 14 it says in this
gospel of the kingdom shall be preached
in all the world for a witness unto all
nations and then shall the end come what
what does it mean by this gospel of the
kingdom what what kingdom is referring
to is it is it the spiritual kingdom of
salvation or is it the second coming or
is it both or what well in Matthew
chapter well in the book of Matthew he
speaks more about the kingdom than any
other of the gospel books Jesus is
always talking about the kingdom of God
the kingdom of heaven in his parables he
uses that phrase he's talking about the
Gospel message that he came to bring and
so it'd be his teaching
the entire essence of the teaching of
the Messiah this gospel this good news
is going to be preached in all the world
and of the Bible you know and then the
end will come
doesn't say everyone will believe it
says it's preached as a witness and then
the in comes okay alright and we're
almost there you know this is exciting
because pastor Russ and I got on a phone
call last night with amazing facts
missionaries we had over 30 different
sites that call them from around the
world and there are people waiting on
Indonesia and India and Africa and
everywhere Europe and they called in we
were talking about the gospel work and
this is where just one ministry amazing
facts there's hundreds of Christian
ministries that are in all different
parts of the world right now and now
through the internet and through
satellite boy and the gospel is going
everywhere absolutely thank you for your
call JD we've got Tony listening in
Kentucky Tony welcome to the program
thank you for taking my call yes sir my
question tonight is about divorce and
remarriage and I guess specifically we
know that the Bible talks about the
situations where it's okay for someone
to get a divorce but in those same
verses it doesn't really seem to talk
about remarriage so my question is is
there any biblical proof that it is okay
for a Christian or for anybody to get
remarried after a divorce save for the
cause of the spouse dying or an
unbelieving well I I guess just for the
spouse dying yeah well the reason for
the Bible defining what is acceptable
cause for divorce if you have any
acceptable cause for divorce you are
automatically eligible to remarry it's
those who do not have an acceptable
cause for divorce that are not eligible
to remarry of course you don't have to
remarry but you have the right to
remarry God is not requiring you know if
if you've got a spouse that has
committed adultery and abandon you then
you can divorce that person they violate
they've violated the Covenant and
then you have the right to marry again
with an innocent conscience
so is that helped a little bit it does
and I guess that that would convince me
but I know of another person I talked to
who says that he insists upon this that
the the divorce is okay but that there
is no text that anybody could use to
defend that that same person who
divorced correctly because they were
cheated on then getting remarried is
there a biblical text that does it or
would it be more like how you explained
it where it's kind of based on it's kind
of an implicit thing where is it pastor
Ross in Romans where Paul said that if a
woman's husband dies she's freed from
that obligation and in being freed from
that it's understood by the context that
means she's free to remarry yes so at
least if someone is widowed they're free
to remarry Abraham's Sarah died he
remarried cateura
and he was free to do that and I know
there are probably other examples in the
Bible of oh yeah who was it that
Ezekiel's wife died I think Hosea's wife
died so yeah and then you can remarry so
divorce illegitimate divorce is the same
as if your spouse dies in your widowed
you can remarry yeah absolutely you know
pass it up my computer search engine
just must be an apple or III did
something so I can't that's Ross and I
go back and forth like he's TC and uses
Apple so I had a search option here that
just knocked me out of where I was
supposed to be so well Paul talks about
in Romans where I think it's in Romans
he says that if they if a woman's
husband died she's freed from the law of
her husband and that might be Romans 7
yeah well yeah here it is Romans 7 1 or
do you not know brethren for I speak to
those who know the law that the law has
dominion over a man as long as he lives
for the woman who has a husband is bound
by the law to her husband as long as he
lives but if the husband dies she is
released from the law of her husband
so then if while her husband lives she
marries another man she'll be called an
adulteress but if her husband dies she
is free from the law she's no adulteress
though she remarries again same thing
with legitimate divorce as with this
that's the verse I was looking for
thank you Tony hope that helps and we
have a book we can offer on divorce
marriage we do it's called a marriage
divorce and remarry and the number to
call for that he's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven again
808 three five six seven four seven as
for the marriage divorce and remarriage
all right pass that I think I've got my
Bible softer up and running here so
we'll see how that works we got Lotus
listening from San Bernardino Lotus
welcome to the program yeah make sure
your radio is down in the background and
your question tonight yes I'd like to
know so fast that to try to define first
John 5:13 versus hope to be saved or
they know that this well let's read this
for our friends that are driving down
the road these and this is first on 5/13
these things I've written to you who
believe in the name of the Son of God
that you might know that you have
eternal life and that you might continue
to believe in the name of the Son of God
it's at the verse you wanted yes yes and
John 3:16 well it says everlasting so
I've heard class to say that well I hope
to be saved I want you to know that to
be saved is what to me it is more solid
now the Bible the Apostles use both
words even Paul says he calls saw the
second coming the Blessed hope and then
you got John who says I know one place
Paul says I do not count myself to have
apprehended or be perfect and the later
Paul says I know in whom I believed and
I am persuaded that he is able
so it's both a confidence and a hope
and yeah it's wonderful to say we we
know but even in that verse we just read
there where he says you know and that
you may continue to believe now the very
fact that John says in that verse verse
five that you may continue to believe
he's basically say I'm sorry it severs
13 that means that it's possible for a
person not to continue otherwise you
wouldn't say that so he's saying you can
no you have eternal life and as long as
you continue to believe so yeah it's a
confidence we have you know I
Ellis trait it this way Lotus I'm
married to Karen and she's married to me
and we made a covenant and I love her I
don't ever worry about coming home and
finding her with another man we made a
covenant I know her I love her I trust
her and I have confidence on a
relationship she doesn't ever worry
about me so where you have faith and
love you have a confidence about your
relationship now does that mean that
Karen and I are not free to violate that
covenant know we still have that freedom
but we have a love and a confidence so
that's not a concern so it's the same
thing in a relationship with the Lord as
we love Jesus and we walk with Him we
are confident about our salvation all
right well thanks for your call Lotus
again I think we do have a book called
can a saved man choose to be lost
yes and it's writing today I have
another book we don't often give and
it's called assurance yeah
justification made simple yes and so if
you want to know about the assurance we
believe in that the number to call is
883 five six seven four seven you can
ask for two books can I save man choose
to be lost and the surance justification
made simple I think you'll find those
both very enlightening as you study now
Jonathan is listening in Canada Jonathan
welcome to the program
hello pastors hi how are you doing I'm
doing well
so my question is I've been given a
formula between Daniel 9 and it it goes
through the 70 years of the captivity of
Israel right and
the the person who gave it to me drew up
a conclusion of the seven-year
tribulation and the more popular one I
believe it's Revelation 13 now I'm not
fully convinced in a seven-year
tribulation where does the formula for
the biblical three and a half years come
from well you're probably talking about
there's there's a two or three different
interpretations on Daniel nine the two
most popular are what you called the
historic view which is what pastor Ross
and I believe and it's actually what all
the Protestant reformers believed and
then you've got the futurists view the
futurist view is a fairly new
interpretation that's the one that was
made popular by the Scofield Bible and
how Lindsay and then gradually just took
off like wildfire through a number of
charismatic churches so that most
evangelical Christians now believe that
the seven years in Daniel chapter 9 the
last seven years is floating it's like a
hovering time period that's going to be
the time of trouble at the end it's a
very different interpretation than the
historic view the historic take that
last week and they keep it part in other
words it's a whole 70 weeks 490 years
together and it reaches from the command
to restore and build Jerusalem you've
got 490 years up until the stoning of
Stephen when the Supreme Court of the
Jewish nation plugged their ears and
rejected the presentation of the gospel
then the gospel went to the Gentiles in
the next chapter and so you you have two
different views of that can we send you
a study on that because it's it's hard
to give them all those verses and
chapters in just a few minutes yeah
actually yes please that would help a
lot I could use that to further I guess
you'd say prophet I sing to my friends
well when you see this I tell you no
prophecy in the Bible got me more
excited than annual chapter 9 because it
is so clear when you look at it and I
think
interpretation you're gonna see is I've
looked at them all and this to me is
just lightyears ahead of some of the
speculation I've seen it really makes
sense and I think you're referring
pastor Doug to that study called cold
right on time yes I deals with Daniel
chapter 9 and the various time
prophecies again we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and you can ask for the study guide it's
called right on time and we'll send it
out to anyone who calls we've got Chad
listening from Michigan Chad welcome to
the program great my question oftentimes
translated in English he'll write and
I've heard it said that well that's just
referencing the grave but in doing a
little digging there seems to be a
different Hebrew word for graves and she
all seems to be kind of specific like to
the concept of the realm of the Dead and
in Isaiah 14 verses 9 through 11 you see
that imagery of this place if she all
these spirits coming up from she all to
greet to greet these these wicked
oppressive leaders and so I guess I I
can understand it somewhat poetically
but I guess it comes into question like
what what if the people who were writing
it believed in this term as such and how
how do we kind of understand it when
when it seems to be a this was the
understanding that there was this
believe me where everybody went when
they died let me read this for our
friends we've got a lot of listeners
driving down the road so I always like
to when you reference a verse I want to
read it so they know what we're talking
about in Isaiah chapter 14 I'll start
with verse 9 he'll from beneath is
excited about you to meet you at your
coming it stirs the dead for you all the
chief ones of the earth it is raised up
from their Thrones and all the kings of
the nations they shall speak and say to
you how
you also become weak as we have you
become like us your pump is brought down
to Sheol and yours the sound of your
stringed instruments the maggot is
spread under you and the worms cover you
and so ya Isaiah writes with a lot of
poetry you were right about that and
he's basically describing this this
ruler who is going to end up being
terribly humiliated in the next verses I
think that's we're also gonna say that
well you know I just not that I've got
my Bible program up and running pass
today I did a word search on the word
hell there and it's kind of an
interesting just the Hebrew it is
translated into English as grave as pit
as hell as Sheol same word just used in
different verses in different contexts
so you could say pit the pit ease from
beneath II the actual translation so
it's not you know it's not this place of
eternal torment that people think about
it's talking about the grave in
different forms right in a symbolic
sense or poetic sense here and one
reason we know this - it's the same
place King David went and we know he's
saved it talks about you will not suffer
my soul to remain in Sheol and there
it's Psalms 49 actually uses the word
grave yeah same same Hebrew wood so hey
thank you so much Chad I you know I wish
we could take more time we will send you
a free study guide on our the dead
really dead and you may have seen that
and also have a web site called death
truth calm you'll enjoy listening
friends we've just got a few seconds
left in this part of our broadcast we
always have some great closing
announcements I like to thank you for
tuning in and sorry if we did not get to
you June and Kyle and Jessica Edie we're
gonna be here next week God willing keep
studying the word during the pandemic
help us stay on the air friends amazing
facts dot o-r-g click donate we sure
appreciated
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols chart and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stance apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five can't get enough amazing facts
Bible study you don't have to wait until
next week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vo RG DT no amazing backs has
a free Bible school that you can do from
the comfort of your own home it includes
27 beautifully illustrated study lessons
to aid in your study of God's Word
sign up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 1-800 for 257,000
that's one eight four four two one five
7,000
[Music]
for life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF ax0 RG and sign
up for our free Bible study course and
make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at
[Music]